[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Katie is
with us in Concord New Hampshire hi
Katie welcome to the ramsy
show hi oh God this is actually
happening okay breathe Katie it's gonna
be
good holy
moly what's up how can we help
overwhelmed with gratitude this is crazy
okay oh um first I need to thank you for
um everything thank you how can we
help um
so okay Dave you have to promise not to
yell at
me um my boyfriend and I have combined
all of our debt and our bank accounts
and we are um gonel and tense on um our
debt um we have about uh $889,000 left
um we have smashed out all the credit
cards there's no more credit card debt
which is very freeing um so now we're
working on student loan and Auto Loan um
but my question is um my my family and I
have recently joined a church that um
you know my children and I were baptized
in and
um every month you know uh we have our
budget meeting you know and um I'm the
planner and he gets to change my plan
which I don't really like very much but
um my question is every month after
month after month um the church column
um is a bunch of zero because um I feel
like I don't really have anything to
give
um and I just I want to be able to give
um the 10% of our income is when are you
getting
married ask
him um I've actually had this
conversation with him um I've actually
been married twice before um so and his
how long have you been
dating we've been dating for over a year
okay if you're if you're willing to
completely combine your finances you
should never do that unless you're
married and then you should do it
immediately but this is very dangerous
for you very
vulnerable yeah yeah so um if either
take your finances back apart or get
married what was his response when you
brought it up to him
marriage um so we we talk about it we we
want to get married his thing is like he
wants to be able to provide picture
perfect for me um sorry that's not an
option yeah there's no such thing I got
a hunch here real quick Katie what ises
what does he make income wise and what
do you make separate
those um okay so I make um one two three
like 4,000 a month okay give or take
okay what does he and he makes
about uh 55 okay 100 roughly
okay and I actually have more debt than
he does okay well number one let's just
back up back the bus up here either get
married in the next 30 days or separate
your finances yeah this is very
dangerous for you I'm scared for you
okay you should not be paying his debt
he should not be paying your debt when
you're not married you are going to get
it's going to put a strain on the
relationship something's going to blow
up and one of you is going to get left
in an unfair disadvantage due to this
broken system that you should not be
using I'm not yelling at you I just want
good for you I love you I want you to
win then the then once you've made the
decision to either separate your
finances or combine them because you're
getting married immediately not next
year okay um
then I mean this is not something you
need to plan for two years painter get
off the ladder and then um then then
once you decided all that then we can
come to your question how do we put
you've just started attending church how
do you put Church in the budget well you
don't put Church in the budget you put
God and generosity in the budget and for
those of us that are Evangelical
Christians the first stage of Baseline
generosity is a tenth of our income
going to the local church but that is an
act of
worship that's an act of of not trying
to buy God's favor he he doesn't need
your money he says to do this because he
wants to turn you into a generous person
because generous people are much better
children and you and I are better
children of God when we are generous us
and so he's trying to turn us into that
and that's what the tithe was
established for it's not established as
a rule it's not established as a shaming
mechanism by religious zealots it's
established as a method of teaching us
the power of generosity when it's a
regular rhythm in our lives and so were
I you I would live on 90% of my income
and be giving a tenth of my income to my
local church if I'm a person of faith
that's not a condemnation but it's what
I have done for 40 years and it's worked
really really well for me and there's no
guarantee you're not going to have bad
times there's no guarantee of anything
it's just an act of generosity and it's
teaching us the rhythm of generosity a
baseline start and I was in a church
when I was going bankrupt Katie in my
20s as a baby Christian and um there
were people there that would say things
like well you know God protect text you
if you tithe and I went uh missed that
part went
bankrupt I missed that well and then I
had one old blue-haired lady say well
you just didn't have enough faith and I
said honey I didn't have anything left
but Faith they took everything else so I
mean come on yeah so uh broken Doctrine
broken
theology uh but and so you can get
twisted up in all that toxic garbage or
you can just say hey I'm going to live
life with an open hand and I'm to be a
generous person because generous people
smile more generous people are less
often depressed generous people are
better at relationships cuz who wants to
be in a relationship with a selfish
person no one right and so the act of
generosity is a becomes a character
quality and it changes your whole life
and so yeah I'm going to put that at the
top of my list of things to do
absolutely but not as a legalism rule
yeah absolutely right that is really
scary Doctrine and it's what drives a
lot of people away from the faith if you
think you got to give God money to get
something good from him that is that is
a recipe for frustration and Desperation
yeah as if he needs his your permission
to bless you right you know and and as
if his Blessing is dependent upon you
giving him a nickel good gracious as if
he if he wanted your money he'd take it
to a big greasy spot where you were
sitting I mean he's God I mean come on
you need your money that's not the point
the point and and so don't be shamed by
K and don't be going because I heard the
guilt oh every month I feel bad cuz
there's nothing in the church column
well I mean put something in there but
don't do it out of Shame do it out of
hey I want to learn a different way of
living that includes
generosity and it includes a
smile and it includes being married to
this guy You' fallen in love with and
combining your whole life not just your
money and uh let's do the whole deal
let's go game on but don't pay someone's
debts ever and don't let someone pay
your debts that you're not married to
you're going to get yourself in a pinch
been doing this a long time and I never
see good of it it ends as delone says
all the time this ends in
Ash o that's a pretty harsh statement
but it does it just the thing thing
Burns to the ground so I I want you to
win kiddo we love you and I'm happy that
you're and your family are in a good
church and it sounds like you're
starting your journey there um and or
resetting your journey there that's
awesome any of that I'm cheering you on
Ken's cheering you on we want you to win
um and um no we're not yelling at you
that's not what we do um we we yell at
Concepts not people but um yeah don't
you know those of you that are shacking
up and aren't getting married you can do
that if you want to do it I won't be mad
at you I'm not going to yell at you um
but don't combine your money don't
combine your money cuz you're going to
get burned don't buy a house for
somebody you're not married to you're
going to get burned I get it all the
time in here it's all the time and
you're just setting yourself up you make
dumb decisions like that you get
yourself burned we don't want that for
you